attention you want followers you want
dollars you can't deny that and to deny
this being is being facetious there
there is a benefit of being the most
entertaining popping YouTube channel
there is a selfish benefit none of us
are perfect from it but my biggest thing
is that when you realize you know what I
truly want to impact the most
individuals and if I'm gonna do that
bring in the most ratchet girls on a
show called wife Academy do you know
what so-called term school and bh1 yeah
it's a charm school someone when I was
explaining this idea somebody told me
about China yeah or Bad Girls Club
that's exactly what you're trying to do
yeah like that to me is like yo that's
just pure VH1 reality is so garbage if
you're truly trying to make a change but
find teachable women there's a whole
community of teachable women in today's
world who want to learn who want to grow
who want to be better wives
because if you make it the most
entertaining show then you get the
people that actually want to learn no
that's because it hits because you hit
the mode most people so the one it
resonates with it's not just gonna be
like I told you I'm gonna be doing it
here's the reality you you and I both
understand audience capture yeah let's
keep it 100 because you either you're
oblivious to how YouTube works or you're
being utterly delusional in front of
your people which I don't believe you're
delusion I believe you're very smart
women so I hope it's not that you're
oblivious to this how it works there is
audience capture here perfect example if
I am going to make um Chick-fil-A what
kind of food do I want I want chicken my
mindset going here is I want chicken if
Chick-fil-A starts serving Seafood I
don't want Seafood from Chick-fil-A so
Chick-fil-A has captured an audience
that wants these things so for for
Content creators if your primary form of
content is let's say playing video games
you're like you know what I'm gonna do
video game content to be able to reach
the masses and all of a sudden I'm gonna
then teach my my my uh rocket science
but it wouldn't just be hoes that's what
I'm telling you I'm doing it too I'm the
main character on my channel no I'm the
main character yes I am you literally
just said it's you your friend and a
bunch of hoes you're not being serious
yeah let's keep so let's stop playing
this game this is why it's not it's not
a game this is why the red kill people
you guys are acting dumb you know what
you're doing you know you're doing this
for them no I I'm gonna lie I have a
Chinese game I have a hundred percent
said it is going to be an entertaining
show you're a great animals who don't
want to learn come on how do you how do
you know they don't want to learn you
said that biggest thing yeah
you can you can trick the people in
there you're not tripping I'm not
tricking anybody why do you keep you
keep like accusing me of things and it's
just like yeah okay okay are you is this
too much for you no I can calm down no I
thought we were having fun okay you want
entertainment right you want views
you're the one who said you want
entertainment okay now I'm giving you
entertainment
you want entertainment having a good
time
we're having a good time ladies and
gentlemen my point is that I understand
that you have to provide entertainment
and when you make things stale like
broccoli nobody's gonna want it I
understand that but what I'm saying is
that if you're telling me the biggest
issue that's that's destroying Society
is is is the point that you brought up
about the issues between marriage and
you believe your solution is a Academy
for women well I want to get the women
who want to actually learn why won't you
get the healthy positive women the way I
think about it is I'm gonna have more
screen time anyway and then you get like
the it's like you always want to
contrast of personalities and you're
trying to make it funny and so it's like
it's funny or is it be helped I think I
think you can do both and maybe maybe
you feel like it can only be one maybe
maybe can you can you let me you keep
cutting me off as much it's actually my
Channel today it's my Channel today it's
not like and it's like I I I think you
can be entertaining and helpful at the
same time I just think I just think you
reach the most people through
entertainment and I I feel like if if
you have an entertaining and you have
one character that's actually trying to
learn or two characters that are
actually trying to learn it's like
you're they're trying to overtake like
the world of hoes and it's like then
then you can see the progression and I I
feel like you'll still have people that
want to learn that'll sign up but that's
just my that's just my thing about it
what so Michael like like I'm I'm going
to have more screen time than the other
girls because it's my show so here's a
question yeah season three you end up
getting married uh-huh you're no longer
on the show because you obviously can't
be no sorry you can't be in this school
multiple seasons are you getting kept
back no no I mean the what happened
season two oh you're right yeah then I
would host you're right you're right
yeah yeah think about it you can't if
you're if you're in if you are in
marriage Academy for seven years in a
row you're like yo something's wrong
with this chick right here I'm seeing
this seven years yeah so after season
one yeah
now you're now you're gonna be now
you're gonna be coaching yeah who's all
going to be in an audience who's gonna
be in the audience who's gonna be the
students now well it's kind of like a
it's kind of like a show like it would
be you would you would have a mix it
would be a mix 50 50 90 10. I don't know
if he's I'm just trying to get season
one out okay do you I I really haven't
thought about season two three four and
you keep having to like Hammer me out
the details I thought honestly you told
me this you had a plan I thought you had
a plan I thought you had to when people
are the first season first season one
year three year five years not really
honestly this whole this whole content
creation thing I've just kind of like
done the best I can I don't really think
I had to be fair but I know yeah but
it's like it works out pretty well I'm
almost at 500k subscribe subscribe
honestly that to me if I'm being real I
know a lot of you guys love those
numbers to me those numbers don't mean
anything okay because it's about it's
about generally what are you out to do
because I think like and this is where
am I picking on you a lot of people in
the space they genuinely the scoreboard
is views it's subscribers it is dollars
the scoreboard for me is seeing men's
lives transform and seeing actual
healthier families in today's society
seeing the system and seeing all those
unhealthy things no longer existing and
now there's better men better women
better better future that's the
scoreboard for me and so at the end of
the day every single decision that we
make should be for the purpose of
creating healthier men and women in the
future and so if you're if the
scoreboard go ahead I lost my train of
thought yeah go ahead
it's a scoreboard it's simply if you use
likes and subscribers and then I respect
that keep it 100. keep it 100 I'm not
mad at it why can't you do both why does
it have to be one or the other you can't
do well but be honest you can't do
anything if you don't make money but
here's the deal yeah like but be honest
what you're doing
what are you if you're being 100 real
primarily can you be honest primarily it
because there's nothing it's like 50 50.
so there's no perfect
what's that word asymmetrical split
right if you're being honest you're just
building this as you fly you don't know
these things you're new here you don't
really know what's going on and so to me
I'm not holding you to the same stands I
hold myself to a lot of those other
content creators they're older men
they've been doing this for a long time
there's a lot of wisdom that I'm like yo
I'm a 32 year old man I'm just figuring
life out I'm a young man I don't have
the wisdom as these older dudes so I
hold them to higher standards you we're
just having fun you're new here yeah
you're just figuring stuff out you're
just copying pasting some of their what
they say to you you're trying this out
you're gonna learn you're going to be
better five years from now you're gonna
be a totally different person how old
are you I'm 25. you're super young
you're young see I don't I never get mad
at the Young Red Pill guys and girls
because you guys are young it's like
it's like a young feminist oh yeah I
don't want no babies 25 sure I'll see
you at 35 with your beautiful husband
and your children and so to me my
pushback is I get that you're not where
I get that you're not where you need to
be right now and it's okay because
you're on your journey but my biggest
thing is that if we are being honest and
we're saying that if this is the big
like they're telling me the biggest
issue in today's society is to break
down the family the biggest issue is the
law if these are the biggest issues and
I'm like why is not 90 80 70 of the
energy being put into these things if
this is truly the biggest issue I truly
believe the biggest issue is that we're
not building strong competent men that's
why I sacrifice everything that I own
and everything that I've done to put all
my energy into that I am as Pastor Beth
David said that David said A True
Believer in what I'm communicating and
so to me I just got to be honest if
you're simply doing this for fun for
views for life you're just figuring
things out call it for what it is but
let's not play this game like we're
these altruistic individuals who don't
care about these other things when we do
I've never played a game where I pretend
that I don't want to make money and get
subscribers like I want that too but I
just think you can do both I think you
can advocate for men and make money at
it I don't see the problem and the
reality and I don't I think you can
start to build Solutions and make money
like I think everything like you can't
build anything without money you can't
build that like nothing
no one's doing a charity here if you're
telling me my my goal is to help men and
I need to make money but the way I'm
making money is hurting a man you're I'm
not hurting Matt you don't you said you
I didn't say you okay
am I hitting a sore spot that's how you
is this what bothers you at night no no
you're not hitting anything are you sure
yeah
I'm having a good time guys but it's
like it's like I don't know I just I
think you can do both of course yeah but
my so my thing is that as you grow you
realize that dang some of the stuff I
was doing yesterday was I thought was
which I thought was good it's not
beneficial today it's not moving people
for forward today it's not helping men
and women today once you understand
those things then you as an individual
can adjust can improve and you will you
definitely will you're 25 you're just
you're new to the space you're gonna get
so much better and so what I'm what I'm
communicating is that if there was a
healthy balance right we've gone on too
far on the entertainment side and we're
not on into the true life transformation
side and in regards not saying you
not saying you but I'm saying the
content in general and that's what I've
seen because I've been watching this
content for a long time you're new here
I've been watching this for a very very
long time the people that you mentioned
I've been watching them for a very very
long time and to me there there is an
evolution and there's a growth which I
love what I was seeing out of Kevin I
love what I'm seeing out of Andrew Tate
and that's what we need to make the
society a better place and that's all
I'm advocating for as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and to
monetize on a daily
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible